Ian Bremmer is the founder and president
of Eurasia group a global political risk
consulting company good morning and good
to have you on the program so we learned
from Norah's I interview with president
moon last week that there seems to be a
somewhat different approach to dealing
with North Korea between President Trump
and president moon what is a win for the
two of them coming out of this day of
meetings oh my god I guess getting
through it this is not an easy meeting
like it was when Prime Minister Modi
from India came in earlier in the week
South Korea before the impeachment of
president Park was getting squeezed with
heavy sanctions from China because they
were working more closely with the
United States on North Korea supporting
this THAAD missile defense system now
this new opposition Liberal opposition
party leader president moon that's just
been elected he says I want to talk to
the North Koreans he's more interested
in a sunshine policy and he absolutely
wants to push back on the Americans so
that the China economic relationship can
go well again it's incredibly hard for
him to balance these things I'm so glad
you're here because well some people are
distracted with other stuff that's going
on
this is incredibly consequential and
Mike Allen and Axios reports today that
something happened that in there was a
big White House meeting this president
is about to impose tariffs as high as
20% on China on other countries for
steel firstly all that mean well so what
that is in the context of what had been
the single best meeting for Trump in
foreign relations since he became
president was the magic of Mara lotto
when she's and ping met with him right
but he's changed it completely in the
last few days we now have yesterday's
sanctions against the Chinese bank two
individuals and a corporation because of
engagement with North Korea that's new
we have the intention of putting steel
sanctions against the will of a lot of
the cabinet against a lot of countries
most importantly China we have a new 1.4
billion dollar military deal to the
Taiwanese switch in the last 24 hours
the Chinese have strongly protested
against all the while the North Korea
relationship is getting worse South
Korea is in the most challenging
geopolitical situation right now of any
developed country in the world and what
a time
for president moon to be here in
Washington so how does that affect then
dealing with North Korea yeah
it's gonna make it much harder right I
mean I think you know what we know is
that over the last twenty years we've
had a series of Democratic and
Republican presidents that have seen
North Korea as just too challenging and
so let's just pass it off for our
children and now you know they have more
nukes they have more advanced cyber
capabilities they have more advanced
ballistic missile capabilities and Trump
is saying I'm gonna do something about
this now the good news is because Trump
doesn't really care about human rights
his ability to work with the North
Koreans and say I want to cut a deal and
if he did frankly he'd get a Nobel that
he deserved more than Obama's but
there's also a possibility that we end
up with a direct confrontation with the
North Koreans and before either of those
two things happen the us-china
relationship is going to start to break
because the Americans are pushing and
the Chinese don't want what about the
death the ending I can't stop thinking
about the death of otto warmbier all of
this it's so tragic to anybody who knows
this story does that affect their
strategy at all in North Korea you know
not really a mistake so Otto's father
was extraordinary in the way he spoke to
the American people in the press
following this tragedy but it was really
interesting to see that Trump himself
and the White House did not use that to
say that's it we're not doing diplomacy
were coming after these guys hard he is
leaving the door open for direct
meetings between the United States and
North Korea I think that's interesting
so who has the lead here I mean it's
been his established policy there'll be
six-party talks every six nations deal
in North Korea yeah is everyone gonna go
their own way now does the United States
stately just South Korea does China
who's gonna determine the course of
these negotiations had been doing more
with the Americans on North Korea they
joined multilateral sanctions under the
end of the Obama administration in part
because at that point Trump had already
been elected and so they like let's show
that we can be constructive they did cut
back on coal purchasing from North Korea
they did shut down direct Air China
flights between Pyongyang and Beijing
but that's not anywhere near enough to
force the North Koreans at the table at
this point now the Americans are taking
the lead we have to get to Russia face
to face what are you looking for what do
you what do you think the strategy will
be there
on both sides well look I think that
this is gonna be more of a media event
than a substantive meeting he has met
with Trump has now met with every major
leader in the world except Putin and
it's this is the big wind-up right
because this is the one that no one
wants him to do but everyone is
titillated by we're gonna watch the body
language we're gonna see if they're
smiling the media is gonna go nuts John
McCain and Lindsey Graham same thing
right now says that he has no agenda
that the president has no agenda is that
appropriate for them to say that because
if they'd said he had an agenda that was
just written up by Rex Tillerson the
Secretary of State no one was gonna
believe it a focus on it anyway don't
think it man but there's a lot of her
Putin have an agenda as a question
well his agenda has been to undermine
the transatlantic relationship to
undermine American interests in the
Middle East and Eastern Europe and he's
been effective at that but you know
ultimately the scale of these
investigations which are now very
seriously lawyered up which means that
they feel like they have a lot to go on
that is constraining the ability of the
United States do anything with Russia so
if Putin believed if he did believe that
Trump was actually good for him he has
to be reconsidering that at this point
right yeah you infirm I think you love
it when you come to the table Thank You
Anne